[Music]
hey everyone welcome to harry potter
theory today we're going to be looking
at muggle wizard affairs throughout
history when we crack open our history
books and take a look at famous events
and conflicts between muggles and the
wizarding world you might be surprised
at what you find before the
international statute of wizarding
secrecy which was established in the
year 1692
wizards weren't exactly unknown although
even at that time many considered the
concept of witches and wizards
outlandish there were plenty of people
who had first-hand experience with
members of the wizarding world
in fact in different corners of the
world at varying times entire countries
were swept into anti-magic crazes that
threatened to destroy almost every magic
using man woman and child in their
community
today we're going to take a look at some
of these events and their long lasting
legacy as we discuss the history of
muggle and wizard affairs
if you think of the modern world then
the fact that muggles and the wizards
don't intermingle is a foregone
conclusion
after all the ministry of magic had
worked tirelessly for centuries in order
to keep their constituents a secret
but when we look back in time to the
earliest records we find a very
different landscape in the official
history of the wizarding world the
earliest date documented is 382 bc
that's the year that a roman ancestor of
garrick ollivander the wand maker from
diagon alley in great britain created
their first branch in ancient rome
there's more than a 1 000 year gap
between that date and the next listed
event in official wizarding records
so if we were to try and guess what
happened and how the wizarding world
might have interacted with muggles of
that time will have to rely on our
detective skills
sometime around the 10th century all
four founders of hogwarts were born
after meeting they founded the school in
a remote region of scotland but their
union was short-lived eventually salazar
slytherin's intolerance and his hatred
for muggles and mudblinds rose to a
boiling point when the other three
founders decided they could tolerate no
more sutherin took it upon himself to
leave and continue his study of magic on
his own
but when we look closer at southern's
life we'll find that his hatred of the
non-magical people of britain was more
complicated than simple prejudice and
was a direct reaction to what was
happening around him
in muggle records of that time they
almost exclusively wrote about magical
creatures wizards and witches as evil
beings and with the eventual rise of
christianity across europe muggle
histories were taken up by monks and
theoligians
not willing to allow another power
structure stand in the way of the
growing authority of the church these
clergies took pagan writings even
further
and declared many magical beings were
connected to satan
even before the salem witch trials of
the 17th century the penalty for magic
was often death
so salazar's prejudice although
problematic for enrolling mudbloods at
hogwarts wasn't without reason
through the dark ages and later middle
ages witches and wizards continued to
straddle the line between communities
the laws regarding concealing yourself
from muggles weren't as ironclad as they
would later become in the 18th century
when the ministry of magic was founded
in this early time non-magical humans
seemed to be painfully aware of the
magical world
often muggle sources described dragons
manticores and other ferocious beasts
that preyed on their communities
even the official histories of the
ministry of magic cite that a reason for
relocating many magical creatures to
wildlife preserves was at least
partially
due to their predation on non-magical
people
while wizards and witches could easily
defend themselves with their mastery of
spells and potions
pre-industrial muggles rarely had access
to weapons that could slay magical
beasts
as the years passed and occasional
witch-hunts rose and fizzled out across
the world the international wizarding
community became more and more connected
while trying to build their
international collective their
leadership couldn't help but worry about
the increasing number of hunts and
executions that targeted witches and
wizards
in the 1300s in response to the
popularity of burning witches at the
stake the flame freezing charm was
developed
prior to this wizards and witches were
just as vulnerable to death by burning
as anyone else
but if they used this charm they were
invulnerable to fire and in fact it made
the flames feel pleasant
much later in 1492 nicholas de mimsie
porpington found himself on the wrong
end of an axe just a day prior he had
been standing in line behind a
noblewoman lady grieve
and when he tried to fix the poor
woman's teeth he gave her massive tasks
instead
it was easy for the local authorities to
spot that he was a wizard so they
arrested him threw him in jail and then
planned to chop his head off in the
morning as the students of hogwarts
would learn much later when the ghost of
nicholas recounted his tale
it took the executioner 45 attempts to
cut nicholas's noggin off
but even then a strand of flesh held it
to his neck only 50 years earlier a
french woman named lizet de lipa was
also discovered using magic and sent to
the executionist block
but unlike nicholas lizette wasn't
stripped of her wand before being tossed
into jail as she awaited her death she
transformed herself into a white rabbit
and leapt out of the cell
as these hunts for magic users continued
the persecution of wizards and witches
by the non-magic community presented
other problems
during this time quidditch became the
most popular sport amongst a wizarding
youth but the sight of young men flying
around in the sky aboard their
broomsticks often would create hysteria
amongst nearby muggles
and this eventually would lead to more
witch hunts and executions
in order to combat this local quidditch
officials declared that no match could
be played within 50 meters of a
michael's dwelling
when this proved to be insufficient it
was increased to 100 meters
but even that didn't stop wondering
muggles from spotting the games
the 100 meter limit was eventually
increased to the maximum
quidditch could not be played in any
area where muggles could see it and the
penalty for breaking this rule was quite
harsh even by medieval standards
although for many witches and wizards of
this era
they would have chosen no other time to
live
in the 15th century a cunning witch
named hannah cockleford used her ability
to cast charms to sabotage local nobles
at one point during a public jousting
match between the despicable earl of
panchli and a child
hannah cast a charm shielding the boy
the blunt force of the impact sent the
earl flying and reduced his mental
capacities to that of a toddler for the
rest of his life
their ability to intervene in the
affairs of muggles must have been
gratifying
had witches like hannah lived much later
during the time of the ministry of magic
they would have been far more
constrained in their ability to dole out
justice by the 17th century the clash
between the wizarding world and muggles
seemed to be at all-time highs
in the new world the salem witch trials
were in full swing
for two full years the puritans who
lived in salem condemned nearly two
dozen witches of horrible crimes
although many of the people who faced
death weren't actually members of the
wizarding world a few of them were in
fact witches
and to this in addition to the witch
hunts back home in europe weighed
heavily on the minds of leadership in
britain at the same time some of mary
lou bareburn's ancestors paraded around
the continent as members of the scourers
these were renegade wizards who would
take any job for money ranging from
bounty hunting to selling innocent
witches to crazy puritans who wanted to
kill magic users within the same century
a criminal wizard terrorized muggles in
england using a special unlocking charm
a thief named eldon ellsrickel went on a
robbery spree in london stealing more
than he could ever need before
ultimately dying at the hands of his own
noon do all of these events eventually
drove the wizarding community to sign
the international statute of wizarding
secrecy which declared all magical
beings must conceal themselves from
muggles this was the last desperate plea
by the leaders of the wizarding world to
try and protect themselves and their
children from persecution at the hands
of the non-magical community
after all they had pleaded with william
iii and married the second to enact new
laws to protect witches and wizards but
they refused with the passing of the new
statute violence against wizards dropped
significantly
the long list of new rules which
included wearing muggle clothes when out
in public and barring wizards from
participating in muggle sports
dulled the lives of many wizards and
witches
many notable families including the
malfoy's complained that they shouldn't
have to live like this
hiding from the people they considered
to be they're inferiors but the results
didn't lie for the first time in
centuries witch hunt started to decline
and arrests for use of magic were at all
time lows
the newly formed ministry of magic in
britain and its sister agencies in
countries around the world made sure
that every nation kept their magical
communities concealed and although there
were a handful of breaches
it was nothing that a few forgetfulness
charms couldn't solve
from the 18th century to the modern era
the lives of muggles and wizards were
successfully separated so much so that
muggles by and large consider wizards
witches and magical creatures as nothing
more than fairy tales
and that's it for this video if you
enjoy the content please like the video
and subscribe to the channel
until next time remember
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live